all the ways that you are aware of to destroy a solid mass tumor other than conventional
surgery. Here's what I'm aware. Cryooblation, that's using cold therapy to destroy the
tumor. Radio surgery, that's using radiation. Microwave ablation, that's using microwave
current. Now again, some of these are not even going to be available to people. Microwave
ablation, there's a really deep video on YouTube if they haven't pulled it out. I think it
was Cleveland Clinic in the hospital. Cleveland Clinic was doing microwave ablation of a breast
tumor. And it was pretty cool video. They had great results. Now I haven't heard anything
about that since then. So I don't know how much of that has been done really sadly because
they probably can't charge 100,000 dollars for it. And recently still in clinical trials
is histotripsy, which uses sound waves. Now there's some really neat videos using sound waves.
It's kind of like hypersonic waves under a CT scan to show how you are destroying tumor cells,
really deep videos that I don't know when that will ever be out for real use. So I don't know.
Are there any other procedures that I'm aware of? Well there's evidence that I would agree
that using any of these antipersthermia, I would add that to the mix, can destroy a solid tumor
mass. But it does they don't always, even with the best technicians and technology, it's still not
going to necessarily destroy that mass. I know there was Dr. C. Machini was doing injections of
hydrogen, what was he doing? He was doing injections into tumor masses. This is an Italy,
a number of years ago and he got thrown into prison for it. I know of another doctor in Europe
who did ozone injections near around tumor masses and he claimed to have some success with that,
though I've had some negative things with that have been done. Zinc injections in the prostate
gland has been done some cases, really good results, some cases, no results, whatsoever. The truth is
nothing is going to work 100% of the time. It's just not. So yeah, I know that there's a lot of
people trying different things and a lot of things are working and in a drawing attention of the medical
establishment, one example would be what questions you asked before about bed bed is all that I've
impacted it. It's only because that there's been duorous success stories that the medical establishment
has to start looking at these things. It's really forcing their hand to start looking at those
these things, though they put it made fun of it for years and years and years. Same thing with
Rick Simpson oil, they have to start addressing that these things actually can work and sometimes can
work just as good or better as in chemotherapy with less side effects.